Andrew take words that he's about to get
assassinated in one tweet he said if
they kill me I'd love you all and
another he said I'm preparing my body to
absorb the brutal kinetics of piercing
lead as all other silencing attempts
fail and stage 3 approaches I anticipate
a bullet would be the chosen utensil of
pacification after all this is what Tay
said way before he got arrested the
point where I actually truly believe
they're going to try and kill me I
understand that you get three strikes in
this game
strike one is they try and shut you up
and discredit you which I've just been
through strike two is they try and put
you in jail for no reason and strike
threes they kill you